did you realize that over a billion
people on this planet are deficient in
iron
i was actually pretty surprised to hear
that so today we're going to talk about
iron deficiency anemia
so here are the symptoms fatigue
pale like you're losing color brittle
nails
you get those little grooves in your
nails hair loss
thinning of the hair twitching
feeling irritation pica
you crave dirt or clay
number nine you have the urge to consume
ice or chew on
ice and number ten restless leg syndrome
now there's actually more but these are
the main ones now the question is
what is causing this well
excessive menstruation okay excessive
bleeding
and by the way if you're female and your
cycles are very heavy
that means you have estrogen dominance
i'm going to put a link down below for
you to watch later
but there's some things you can do to
reverse that problem
number two ulcers it could be an ulcer
in the stomach
or even the small intestine that you
don't even know about
number three hemorrhoids i have a very
good video on this
um you want to support your liver
there's a really good remedy
i also have a remedy on this as well i'm
going to put the link down below it's
involving
taking zinc number four colon cancer
could potentially
cause anemia number five dietary
you're a vegan and you're only consuming
beans and grains and plants
those food have what's called non-heme
iron and you only absorb a very very
small amount it's like 1.4 percent
of the iron so you'd have to consume a
tremendous amount of plants to get your
iron the problem is
a lot of the plants and grains have
certain things like oxalates
or phytates that block iron
the best source of bioavailable iron is
called heme iron
is from seafood red meat
poultry eggs and even insects have a
high level of heme iron
just in case that you may get that urge
you know late at night if you
want a snack and i'm being very
sarcastic all right number six
certain antibiotics can deplete you of
iron
number seven low stomach acid a lot of
people have this
they don't even know it as you age you
lose the stomach acid and now you cannot
absorb
certain minerals especially iron
and even calcium number eight
malabsorption if you have some type of
problem in your colon or you're missing
a gallbladder or you had surgery as in
gastric bypass
that can leave you with a hard time
absorbing iron
and number nine and this is fascinating
i'm going to create a separate video
just on this
but inflammation can deplete
your iron how well
both good bacteria and bad bacteria as
in pathogens
need iron to grow and what happens
within your immune system your body
as well as your good bacteria tend to
lock up or bind iron
during an infection during a fever
and during inflammation so what happens
as a survival mechanism your body
prevents the pathogens from getting a
hold of the free iron
and that is one strategy to help limit
their
growth now what's supposed to happen is
after the infection the inflammation
goes away
but what happens if you have chronic
inflammation
because you have some type of autoimmune
condition rheumatoid arthritis
lupus or whatever that is going to end
up depriving your whole body
of a lot of trace minerals iron being
a very specific one and so the more
chronic the inflammation
the more anemic you could be
now you might say well i'll just go
ahead and solve this problem by taking
more iron right
well you're going to actually feed the
pathogens and then they can actually
grow and you'll create an imbalance
so how do you solve that what you do is
you get rid of the actual
source of the inflammation there's a
couple things that i would recommend
i'm gonna put the videos down below but
number one fasting
periodic prolonged fasting is essential
and a lot of vitamin d
both of those can help reduce the
inflammation
without adding in the iron for the
pathogens
so now you know the symptoms and what
causes anemia
and if you haven't seen my video on
chronic inflammation and anemia
i'm going to put it up right here check
it out
you